Hello Freak bitches.
So what did you guys do for
entertainment when you're in there?
Oh Shit.
Did you do stand up in there at all?
Yeah,
I did later on.
That's a crazy question and no one's
really ever asked me that,
but that's what joey got started,
you know?
Yeah.
But it was different because in my last,
my last year and a half,
I'm locked up in Norco,
so all these guards are Mexican,
most of them are Mexican and they're
like,
I used to fucking see you at wild
coyote.
They're like,
I just seen you on showtime.
And they're like,
you're at the Ontario Improv.
So you know,
they got together and uh,
there were like a,
a,
you want to do comedy.
And I was just like,
fuck,
I did not want this.
I did not want like to be popular,
you know what I mean?
Like I didn't want to stay low key.
Yeah.
Then I was just like a,
I don't know,
man,
like I'm offensive,
I'll say something that'll start a riot.
And they're like,
Nah,
Nah.
Other races already said you can say
whatever you want.
Like they planned this shit and I was
like,
all right,
I'll do it.
So all the races.
So you have to have like a little race
knowing.
Fuck yeah.
Hell yeah.
So how does that go down?
It's,
I don't know,
I wasn't involved in it.
It's just so they had to meet with maybe
the guard went up to the white rep,
the black wrap and all the reps was
like,
hey man,
check it out.
You guys.
We have a celebrity comedian here.
That's how they pumped me up.
I was like,
motherfucker can't even get a week at
the Improv but I could get a week in
prison.
That's a good note.
Thank you.
So uh,
it was,
it was.
Oh man,
it was weird.
I was scared as hell,
like,
no Mike.
And they put me in the TV room and there
was like 60 straight,
like fools,
like just like come on dog,
make us laugh.
And like,
you know,
they'd never heard my jokes.
So I did my whole set and they're just
like,
oh.
And then I guess one of the cops,
this is the weird part,
is all the cops left their dorms to come
watch this show and they went back and
then they told the inmates,
so when I go to yard the next day the
inmates were like,
hey dog,
how much you charge?
Come do a show in our room.
And I was like,
what do you mean that like I heard you
did comedy and everybody said it was
cool.
All the racist said you were cool.
And I was just like,
I don't think I can go to your dorm did
that's like against the code.
So the cops would be like,
all right everybody give them an item
and you can go in there and perform an
item.
An item is like a soup,
a hot chocolate.
That's how people are paid to show.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it got to the point where I did
every everyone on,
on our yard and I assembled like a
little crew.
I,
I'm,
I taught this guy had an opening for me
because he was cool as Druggie from
whittier.
He was just,
he was stupid.
Fucking taught him how to do standup and
he knew it but didn't know.
He knew it.
He knew it,
but he never did it.
Jack [inaudible] like,
I remember he'd be like eight dog when
I'm on the street.
He has fucked up teeth.
It's like,
I call.
I called girls and I'm like,
they're like,
how's your body?
And he's like,
I just smiled like Chisel.
I was like,
oh,
that's a setup right there.
Like you're just.
He did it.
And uh,
the look on his face was cool man,
but I just remember he was like,
Hey dog,
I'm gonna hit you up when I get out.
We're going to go on the tour.
I'm like,
no,
you're a fucking tweaker ah,
well it's fine.
Because people that can make people
laugh.
If I always tell people,
like,
if you can make your friends laugh,
you can make people,
you know,
laugh.
It's entirely possible.
You could be a comedian.
It's the same thing.
It's just a matter of whether or not you
get these people to allow you inside
their head.
Yeah.
That's kind of what it is,
right?
Yeah.
The true comfortableness.
But you know,
some of them wasn't like I had a rough
time a couple first 10 minutes because
fools are like,
I thought you were going to do George
Lopez his jokes.
I was like,
no,
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not an impersonator.
Like,
like fools were pissed.
They're like,
hey,
you didn't do any member members or
nothing like that.
Oh,
that's funny.
So they just thought,
stand up comedy is kind of like music
now.
Yeah,
like you would just go up there and do
like some hits they didn't know this is
the crazy part is uh,
the award and catches wind of this shit.
And I'm in a program called sap,
it's substance abuse program and I'm
only in it because you qualify for
halftime if you take this program.
So the wardens like,
hey Sacramento's coming down here,
I want to show them a rehabilitated con
or criminal,
whatever.
I'm a felon,
So I was like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
well you do comedy in front of the
program and Sacramento.
But no cussing a no was like,
I think this was the easiest deal I've
ever made.
I said,
look,
I'll do it if you bring me Kentucky
Fried Chicken and Soda Joe.
I was just saying that the talk show,
because you know how like when I first
started getting gigs,
I'd always called joy is they're going
to give me $700 if I go do visalia town,
2000 dumb ass that it.
So after the show he gives me two,
two liters of coke and a fucking bucket
of Kentucky man.
And he was just like,
I remember walking back and everybody
was like,
I gave all my people a piece and it was
just like,
it was Kinda like,
uh,
that movie,
Shawshank redemption when they're
drinking on the roof.
It was like the first time,
like we ate outside food,
like haven't had a soda in years.
So everybody was like,
I was just like,
okay,
get down home.
He was like,
oh,
it was cool.
Wow,
that's fucking cool.
There's something cool about
appreciating something that you,
you just take for granted because you
can get it anytime you want,
but when you're so restricted you get
those things and it's so good.
Yeah.
No,
they loved it.
They loved it and it was cool because
like a lot.
I mean dude,
I made friends,
like there's guys I still talk to.
There's like friends and it was,
yeah,
it was awesome.
Like how can I say that?
How was prison?
Awesome.
But it was like when people say that
about war to men,
you know,
people say that about,
I think human beings need a certain
amount of struggle.
And then when you experienced that
struggle than the non struggle feel so
much better.
You know,
there's,
there's moments where I've talked about
this before,
but I,
when I'm a hunting in Alaska on this
island,
Prince of Wales and it rained every day.
We were there for six days.
Pouring rain,
drenched haver hunting.
Yeah,
we were.
It was the worst,
like as far as like getting wet and just
being soaked and cold all the time to
one of the worst experiences you could
ever go through because you're just,
it's always like 45,
50 degrees pouring rain and you know,
you're sleeping bags with the inside of
your tents.
Wet.
Everything's wet.
But when I came back,
I remember it was sunny out and I called
my friend Steve Rinella who,
uh,
took me with him on this trip I go to.
I've never been happier in my life.
Like the sun is shining like what I
normally just totally take for granted
exact.
I was like,
it's amazing.
I love it.
I'm like,
I'm driving on the street.
Um,
so I don't think I've ever been happier,
but I was that happy because I had gone
through the struggle.
But nobody wants to do that on their
own,
you know?
And when you're kind of forced into a
situation,
I would imagine like being in prison.
Then when you get that Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you get that soda,
you're like,
wow,
we're,
we're fucking living it up right now.
Because I,
I,
I came from a place.
They have this thing,
it's called a fuck.
I forgot what it's called,
but you have money in your books.
Everybody has money and they do like a
sell off.
Or they'll go to the local vons by the
prison and they'll buy.
You can buy sodas,
cookies,
and pizza.
But nobody ever had Kentucky Fried
Chicken in that bitch.
Like to this day,
that's like my.
I want to put that in my.
In my.
Like my bio had Kentucky Fried Chicken
in prison.